[Musique]
certains maîtres accepte de divulguer
les secrets de leur art c'est ce que ce
coiffeur a accepté de faire en coiffant
devant elle certifie il apprend à une
maman le procédé très simple d'une coupe
efficace cette longue mèche deviendra
une mèche souvenir
mais avant elle a un rôle à jouer pour
cela il faut la rouler sur un bigoudis
sur un rouleau
[Musique]
rassurez vous on ne peut pas tout les
cheveux pour les coiffer à part
[Musique]
mais poursuivons notre coup première
étape les mèches sont coupées une à une
assez régulièrement la maman est
attentive
l'autre petite fille réflexe pour
l'heure invisible mais perplexe gérer
deuxième étape
les cheveux sont mouillés cela vous
inquiète mademoiselle cela permet
d'égaliser la poupe
[Musique]
après la leçon les travaux pratiques
mais la jeune patiente n'est pas si
contente que ça
[Musique]
séchoir et brosses et c'est la troisième
étape
mais
vous voyez que la leçon a profité même
si l'enfant était encore et qui sans oui
c'est guy
[Musique]
et puisque les mèches postiches sont à
l'honneur et que les petites filles
aiment bien imiter leurs mamans cette
frange souple sera très amusante à
porter avec une robe habillée en
attendant d'aller dormir dans le coffre
souvenir
[Musique]
peut-être que ce sera bientôt fini
après l'épreuve le sourire
[Musique]
et l'approbation de ses pairs